bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
en direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
l'un des meilleurs spécialistes des
questions de défense et internationales
bonsoir Françoise bourg et merci d'être
là vous publiez les leçons d'une guerre
chez Odile Jacob on a évidemment
beaucoup de questions à vous poser ce
soir on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé en Russie le week-end dernier les
conséquences de cette rébellion avortée
du groupe Wagner le son d'une guerre
Poutine la telle déjà perdu cette guerre
c'est une des questions à laquelle vous
allez répondre ce soir dans la deuxième
partie mais on commence ce soir par
l'escalade dans les banlieues la mort du
jeune Naël tuée par un policier mardi
matin à Nanterre ami le feu aux poudres
une marche blanche s'est tenue dans la
ville et cette bavure policière présumée
soulève de nombreuses questions la loi
de 2017 sur l'usage des armes par la
police est mise en cause alors faut-il
la revoir grand débat avec mes invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le programme vous me suivez
Françoise beau ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
Nanterre épicentre de l'émotion
aujourd'hui la marche blanche qui s'y
est tenue c'est terminé dans les
tensions d'ailleurs elles sont toujours
vives ce soir après deux nuits de
violences
urbaines dans le pays le gouvernement
prend des mesures très fortes on va y
revenir le policier qui a tiré sur Naël
17 ans a été inculpé pour homicide
volontaire et cette mort relance le
débat sur l'usage des armes à feu dans
la police bonsoir Robin Reda et merci
d'être là vous êtes député renaissance
de l'Essonne vous avez Viry-Châtillon
dans votre circonscription c'est
important ces symbolique vont se
souvient des violences de 2016 et cette
circonscription est marquée par des par
des violences depuis hier soir bonsoir
Mathieu Valley bienvenue porte-parole du
syndicat indépendant des commissaires de
police bonsoir Alma Dufour ravi de vous
retrouver vous êtes député insoumise de
Seine-et-Marne vous étiez maritime
maritime c'est écrit là pardonnez-moi et
vous étiez à Nanterre pour cette marche
blanche vous me direz ce que vous avez
senti de cette révolte et de cette
colère les insoumis qui déposent une
proposition de loi pour abroger la loi
de février 2017 on va en parler enfin
bonsoir Fabien Jobard merci d'être avec
nous ce soir vous êtes sociologue
directeur de recherche au CNRS au Centre
de recherche sociologique sur le droit
et les institutions pénales vous êtes
spécialiste de la police sauteur de
politique du désordre au seuil Françoise
bourg ce qui se passe dans le pays nous
interpelle tous donc n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous le souhaitez on
commence par le rappel des faits
Stéphane blackovski donc tout de suite
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
nos chers Stéphane je vous invite à
faire la même chose Françoise bourg
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à vous alors
pour commencer peut-être quelques images
de cet après-midi de la Marche Blanche
organisée à Nanterre ça commençait à 14h
dans un premier temps le défilé se
déroulait sans incident voyait avec des
gens qui accompagnaient la mer de Naël
la victime et puis malheureusement comme
on pouvait le redouter au moment de la
dispersion il y a eu de gros
débordements de nouveaux déchaînements
de violences urbaine qui se poursuivent
en ce moment à Nanterre rassurez-vous
les chaînes infos sont sur le coup pour
nous montrer tout ça donc si on veut
maintenant on va suivre ce qui se passe
mais si on veut redéler le film il faut
peut-être commencer par une image qui
vous allez l'une du Parisien ce matin
une capture d'écran de la vidéo amateur
qui a filmé le drame donc ceux qui l'ont
vu je pense que la plupart d'entre eux
ont dû se dire à le tir du policier
n'était pas justifié en tout cas c'est
l'impression qu'on a eu les deux têtes
de l'exécutif désir n'ont pas pris la
défense du policier le président c'est
un acte inexplicable inexcusable et la
première ministre elle était à
l'Assemblée en dénonçant une
intervention qui semblait pas conforme
au principe de l'intervention donc bien
sûr tout le monde n'était pas de cet
opinion il y a eu des réactions
immédiates de la part de certains
syndicats de police qui disait que dire
que c'est une excusable ben c'est porté
atteinte à la présomption d'innocence du
policier puis Marine Le Pen qui était
grosso modo sur la même longueur d'onde
alors cela dit la justice n'a pas traîné
puisque dès ce matin le procureur des
Hauts-de-Seine s'est exprimé en
confirmant d'ailleurs ce que disait la
première ministrière le policier
n'aurait pas dû tirer ça tient en une
phrase écoutez
le parquet considère que les conditions
légales d'usage de l'arme ne sont pas
réunis
alors par conséquent le policier a été
mis en examen vous l'avez dit pour
homicide volontaire placé en détention
provisoire mais évidemment l'aspect le
plus inquiétant de ce qui se passe en ce
moment ce sont les émeutes qui ont eu
lieu avant-hier hier qui se poursuivent
à Nanterre et ça s'est passé un peu dans
toute la France donc le gouvernement lui
ne pense pas l'interprète pas ça
simplement comme une explosion de colère
regardez ce que dit elle porte parole ce
matin il y voit une attaque organisée
coordonnée contre des symboles de la
République et de fait parmi les cibles
des émeutiers il y avait pas mal de
symboles de la République beaucoup de
commissariats ont été attaqués là c'est
celui de Neuilly-sur-Marne qui a connu
le plus grand des gain des voitures ont
flambées des mairies c'est celle de
Garges-lès-Gonesse qui ont été un
sangliers il y a eu des écoles des
centres d'aide sociale et bien sûr dans
la classe politique chacun y était de
son commentaire en fonction de ses
opinions donc à droite il se trouve que
le patron des républicains est sur la
même ligne que Zemmour il demande l'état
d'urgence comme en 2005 pour rétablir le
calme et à l'autre extrémité du
l'échiquier politique bah on en réclame
pas le calme on pense qu'à une autre
priorité c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui le
disait la justice avant calme un élément
de langage qui a été repris hier sur BFM
par David Guiraud il va se passer ce qui
doit se passer qu'est-ce que vous voulez
moi j'appelle pas à la peur calme
j'appelle à la justice
non pas la révolte non plus mais c'est
les policiers qui doivent se calmer ce
qu'on tuer cet homme
alors évidemment on sait pas comment la
solution la situation pardon va évoluer
cette nuit ce qu'on sait d'ores et déjà
Gérald Darmanin a dit cet après-midi cet
après-midi c'est que les effectifs
polygendarmerie vont être vraiment très
largement renforcé on l'écoute puisqu'il
y avait 9000 policiers gendarmes
mobilisés dont 2000 sur la plaque
parisienne j'ai décidé qu'il y a 40 000
policiers gendarmes ce soir et cette
nuit mobilisés dont 5000 en fait
parisienne alors je vais vous laisser
débattre juste j'ai repensé cet
après-midi à une phrase que pas disait
Gérard Collomb c'était en 2018 lorsqu'il
a quitté le ministère de l'Intérieur une
partie des quartiers sensibles et il
s'inquiétait il disait aujourd'hui on
vit côte à côte mais j'ai peur que
demain on se retrouve face à face donc
si quelqu'un a une idée pour éviter
qu'on en arrive là évidemment c'est le
moment d'en parler merci merci beaucoup
Stéphane on va on va commencer par ce
qui se passe dans le pays et puis
ensuite on reviendra sur ce qui s'est
passé dans avec cette voiture avec avec
ces deux policiers et la mort la mort de
Naël à quoi fait-on face ce soir selon
vous Reba Reda 180 interpellations la
nuit dernière on attend les chiffres ce
soir il y a toute l'Île-de-France qui
est concernée mais pas seulement il y a
eu des incidents à Dijon à Toulouse hier
soir à Brest à Amiens à Lyon
affrontement avec les forces de l'ordre
tire de morte mortier bus incendié avec
un certain nombre de services publics
aussi visé quel mot vous mettez comment
vous qualifiez ce qui se passe en ce
moment
on fait face à une violence qui est un
qualifiable mais surtout qu'il y a un
justifié un justifié parce que sans
prendre à nos forces de l'ordre à nos
pompiers sans prendre au représentants
de l'autorité et sans prendre à des
bâtiments publics à des services publics
à des maisons France service comme
c'était le cas hier dans ma
circonscription à Athis-Mons symbole de
la présence de la reconquête de nos
services publics dans nos quartiers
c'est porter atteinte à notre pays c'est
porter atteinte aux habitants des
quartiers des villes qui vivent
simplement et qui vivent en toute
tranquillité et donc
les réactions très vives sur vous
m'interrogez sur ce qui se passe vous
avez dit vous-même
cette violence vous y attendiez on
reviendra sur les faits les faits ils
ont été extrêmement choquants ils ont
provoqué de la stupeur chez tout le
monde et quel que soit la vie que les
uns et les autres d'avoir sur la
situation c'est la justice
qui fera toute la lumière sur cette
affaire qui nous dira la vérité qui
prononcera la vérité qui condamnera s'il
faut condamner le policier auteur du tir
en question mais la réaction à ça ça
doit pas être plus de violence on est
bien d'accord que lorsqu'on est choqué
par un moment de violence et de tension
il faut que la société anti- les
conséquences et ça pèse pas qu'elle
s'embrase et donc cet embrasement là
encore une fois il est injustifié
injustifiable
Mathieu Valley racontez-nous vous vous
étiez sur sur le terrain qu'est-ce que
vous affrontez précisément 40 000
policiers gendarmes mobilisés dans le
pays c'était énorme 5000 à Paris
seulement violence organisée et
coordonnées à dire le porte-parole du
gouvernement qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça précisément pour vous d'abord j'ai
écouté votre reportage et la chronique
de Blacko David Giraud le député de la
France insoumise que c'est les policiers
qui doivent se calmer moi hier j'étais
sur le terrain et c'est les émeutiers
qui devaient être interpellé plus tôt
parce que hier c'est pas des policiers
qui ont brûlé des écoles des
commissariats un centre des Restos du
cœur dans le département je travaille
des valses du Marne ceux qui n'ont plus
rien pour s'alimenter n'ont que ce
centre pour pouvoir espérer subvenir à
l'ordre besoin minimaux et en fait si
vous voulez ce qui m'affiche c'est que
on attend des élus de la République de
tout bord qui soit pour un appel au
calme on va y venir à la question
politique avec Alma Dufour dans un
instant qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
coordonner organisée c'est-à-dire
qu'hier moi j'ai fait face non pas des
émotic mais à des individus qui avaient
des intentions criminelles ils étaient
là déterminés en découdre avec les
policiers à nous blesser grèvement moi
je suis tombé dans un guet-apens à
Vitry-sur-Seine alors qu'on est en train
de patrouiller avec nos collègues pour
assister des pompiers qui étaient nés
des barricades en feu et on a une
soixantaine d'individus qui nous sont
tombés dessus qu'ils ont lancé une plus
projectile et qui voulaient clairement
d'écoute puisque moi j'étais visé au
visage j'avais mon casque de protection
et j'ai quand même reçu un projectile en
tout cas une bouteille de verre au
visage et pareil sur une autre cité de
choisir le roi ou un de mes collègues
avec qui je travaillais étaient
poursuivi jusque dans hollow le dit même
qui le pilonnait au mortier et
aujourd'hui quand on est déterminé à
tuer des policiers à brûler des
commissariats et à son prendre aux
institutions de la République je pense
que quel que soit le bord politique ça
doit choquer tout le monde et ça doit
être condamné par tout le monde c'est
condamné par au plus haut niveau de
l'État juste pour bien comprendre sur
les préfets ont été réunis Gérald
Darmanin envoyer des messages pour les
forces de l'ordre surtout ne pas
répondre aux provocation éviter voilà
des blessés et voir des morts que vous
allez comment agir concrètement sur le
terrain il y a une forme de retenue mais
vous savez contrairement à ce que
certains pouvaient partie politique
disent la police tue la police assassine
on est des barbares on est des bons à
rien tout sera fait pour éviter les
blessés de policier et la réalité du
métier de policier je sais que même du
four ça vous gêne mais c'est des propos
de votre parti politique et en réalité
moi je suis un policier républicain et
quand on dit que la police assassine la
police Sud dans le cortège auquel vous
êtes juste en lui-même auquel on a
participé cet après-midi moi j'estime
que la police en fait c'est pas un
paillasson sur lequel on essuie
sans vergogne et pour lequel on a aucun
respect voilà même du four vous êtes
interpellé directement par Mathieu
vallée
si on se sentant que tous les policiers
sont des sanguinaires et sont assoiffés
de se délecter de tuer des gens alors
que ce n'est pas vrai vous savez que
vous savez que quand on parle sur ça
quand on est policier l'obsession qu'on
a c'est d'utiliser son arme en dernier
recours quand on a plus aucun choix pour
protéger ma vie mais aussi un jour
peut-être la vôtre face à des criminels
ou des délinquants qui risquent de vous
tuer en l'occurrence on va pas forcément
pour ce qui s'est passé pour pour Noël
faut à la distinguer des choses
simplement vous avez vu vous êtes mise
en cause cette vidéo de votre collègue
député David Guiraud a beaucoup choqué
parce que on s'attend quand même à ce
que l'élu de la République et apaiser
vous est-ce que vous nous dites ce soir
j'appelle au calme est-ce que vous
pouvez le dire et ça me choque un peu on
va pas refaire l'histoire des violences
policières en France c'est justement ça
qui joue aujourd'hui parce qu'on n'est
pas à ma question là
très très précisément ce qu'on demande
c'est des mesures fortes c'est à dire
non non mais en fait on peut pas
découper le débat c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement les
quartiers se trouvent dans un rapport de
force directe très violent et
honnêtement je ne souhaite vraiment pas
qu'un policier soit tué qu'on soit
d'accord qu'on soit clair non non mais
pour lever pour lever les doutes vous
condamnez mais la question qu'il ne se
passe jamais rien sans ce rapport de
force souvenez-vous les marches
organisées par le collectif Adama
souvenez-vous après la mort de Cédric
chouvia il y avait une tentative de
revenir sur la clé d'étranglement les
techniques d'étranglement qu'il y avait
tué Cédric chouvia Le ministère de
l'Intérieur a reculé à peine trois jours
après suite aux pression des syndicats
de police il ne se passe jamais rien
lorsqu'il a des violences policières la
mort de Naël s'il voulait mettre le
débat des choquantes des violences
policières mais est-ce que la fin
justifie les moyens mais la fin justifie
les moyens parce qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas un cas isolé d'accord c'est le 14e
mort en un an pour refus d'obtempérer ça
fait plus d'un mort par mois en France
la France et le pays d'Europe où la
police tue le plus pareil dans le détail
on a préparé un sujet sur cette loi 2017
la problématique systémique vous pouvez
pas comprendre pourquoi les gens se
sentent obligés d'en arriver là pour
obtenir quelque chose et c'est pour ça
que et on est vraiment content que les
policiers étaient suspendus et mis en
examen rapidement encore heureux parce
que c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas
toujours dans toutes les affaires
souvenez vous de la faire Ryana une
jeune femme de 21 ans qui est morte
c'était juste une passagère elle avait
rien demandé à personne d'un véhicule
qui a refusé d'obtempérer à Pigalle il y
a un an l'affaire n'est toujours pas
jugée les policiers sont toujours en
fonction et ils n'ont toujours pas été
auditionnés cette jeune femme non mais
en fait j'entends j'entends mais
j'entends tout à fait simplement je me
dis voilà c'est compliqué c'est toujours
très polarisé c'est des bas c'est
quasiment impossible
et on y reviendra après au-delà de la
faire précise parce que même si le
policier mis en examen il faudra encore
voir les condamnations pénales derrière
ça peut prendre trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans dans tous les faits de violence
policière la plupart sont pas jugés les
pas le chiffre dont on dispose on se
rend compte qu'il y a très très peu de
condamnations très très peu de
condamnations et ça les gens des
quartiers le savent et donc du coup ça
prend du temps prend du temps pour tout
le monde mais particulièrement pour la
police c'est très bien mais je peux vous
donner juste un dernier film parce qu'en
fait on a même pas les chiffres le
ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère de
la Justice ne font pas de statistique
sur les condamnations pénales de
policiers condamnés pour violence
polycérone c'est pas si c'est dur sursis
on sait pas combien on était vraiment
condamné donc on est obligé d'avoir à
faire des enquêtes indépendantes fait
pas des journalistes donc je vous
donnerai ces chiffres sur 213 cas procès
contre des policiers pour violence
policière en 43 ans seul 10 on donnait
lieu à des condamnations de la prison
ferme donc ça non mais voilà si vous
comprenez pas ce tableau vous pouvez pas
comprendre
à quoi on fait face à votre avis on
pense tous à 2005 on se souvient que ça
avait duré trois semaines l'état
d'urgence avait été déclaré très
tardivement on en est pas là est-ce que
vous vous sentez que c'est violence sont
partis pour durer
comment comment vous analysez ça
toutes les analogies peuvent être tirées
effectivement avec 2005 en particulier
parce que il y a un épicentre de la
colère qui est évidemment Nanterre comme
les Technics sous bois en 2005 mais
d'emblée et d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
rapidement qu'en 2005 on a vu que cette
colère a embrasé tout un ensemble de
villes
beaucoup se trouve à l'ouest beaucoup
sont aussi des villes qui ont connu des
épisodes de
d'émeutes d'affrontement de
contestation dans les années qui ont
suivi 2005 la géographie est pas
complètement aberrante des villes qui
sont touchées aujourd'hui en toute état
de cause il y a un point qui distingue
très profondément ce qu'on a vécu en
2005 et ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est
la réaction du politique des politiques
et notamment du gouvernement en 2005 on
était dans une situation de quasi
cohabitation entre un Premier ministre
Dominique de Villepin et un président de
la République Jacques Chirac qui était
affaibli par rapport à un ministre de
l'Intérieur Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait
conçu son ministère comme le tremplin
vers le pouvoir l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 là on a un
ministre de l'intérieur une première
ministre un président de la République
qui très vite comme vous l'avez rappelé
immédiatement
exprimer leur émotion on
interrogation qu'ils avaient par rapport
à ce geste policier que le Président de
la République a qualifié de
d'inexcusables et la justice a réagit je
rappelle que dans l'affaire de la mort
des deuxièmes et Bouna qui a déclenché
donc les émeutes de 2005 la procédure
judiciaire a en effet durée 10 ans
et c'est terminé du reste par une relax
des deux policiers mises en cause les
gestes n'étaient pas les mêmes les
circonstances n'étaient pas les mêmes on
parlait à l'époque de mise en jeu de
d'un délit de non-intervention à
personne en danger ici on parle de d'un
usage homicidaire de l'arme
mais cette cohésion de du politique vers
l'apaisement cette
célérité de la justice à s'emparer du
cas
à le traité
sur la base de poursuite pour homicide
volontaire ça marque une différence
considérable par rapport à 205 est-ce
que ça veut dire que les violences
auxquelles on assiste vont s'arrêter là
maintenant je n'en sais rien je ne veux
rien prédire du tout en tout cas les
conditions sont pas les mêmes
même une minute de silence qui a été
observé dans l'hémicycléaires bien sûr
Mathieu Valley même du four si je peux
terminer mon propos cet usage d'armes à
feu par ce policier fait suite à un
refus d'obtempérer et en France on va
pas dire qu'on utilise son arme les
policiers gendarmes avec un refus
d'obtempérer
je vous écoute attentivement je partage
premier point de vue mais la démocratie
exige que je vous écoute donc je vous
disais que à suite à ce refus
d'obtempérer par ce jeune conducteur de
17 ans il y a eu effectivement par la
suite l'usage de l'arme à feu par un
policier mais en France on tue pas parce
qu'on refuse de s'arrêter le policier
utilise son arme pour protéger sa vie et
celle des autres en l'occurrence est-ce
que vous savez dans notre pays combien
représente dans les refus d'obtempérer
l'usage de l'armée par les policiers les
gendarmes
0,89%. donc quand on dit que c'est
systémique ça veut dire que c'est
systématique la vidéo elle est quand
même et que toute notre institution
la France insoumise il faut qu'elle
arrête de s'essuyer ses pieds sur notre
institution comme elle est suit ses
pieds sur la paillasson à chaque fois en
fait c'est systémique de nous critiquer
parce que on déteste la police on peut
ne pas aimer là mais une police qui agit
dans le respect des droits elle le fait
madame la prof c'est jeune homme est
mort dans des circonstances absolument
terribles et vous laisserez la justice
continuer n'aurait même pas d'enquête et
donc juste terminer sur ce sujet là
c'est que quand l'usage des armes à feu
dans les refuses tempérés représentent
0,89% on peut pas dire que les violences
tue je suis désolé madame tous les
policiers ne sont pas des Sanguinaires
je le répète ne sont pas là par volonté
de tuer ou par passion de vouloir donner
la mort oui ils sont là pour protéger
les gens et vous pourrez
il y a pas mal de syndicats de police et
je vous donne la parole et ensuite on
passe à la loi de 2017 parce que c'est
peut-être ici qu'elle va être changé on
y vient pourquoi les syndicats de police
dénoncent des pressions sur le sur le
parquet j'ai vu j'ai vu passer ça des
pressions du gouvernement sur la justice
après après cette décision de
d'inculpation c'est votre cas quand vous
avez un président de la République un
même borne je sais pas j'étais pas au
courant qu'elle avait suivi ou suivi des
formations aux techniques de sécurité
d'intervention pour juger de l'action de
police moi je suis dans un pays où je
crois en l'état de droit et c'est pas un
président de la République une première
ministre soit des partis politiques
sur cette affaire là on aimerait bien
qu'il soit tout de suite condamné
exécuté en place publique et qu'on passe
à une autre affaire moi je veux juste
qu'en fait que la présence innocence
qu'on exige pour tous les Justiciers et
les citoyens elle s'applique à ce
policier et ça veut pas dire que je
préjuge de la suite et de l'action de ce
policier mais vous savez comme je suis
policier je suis humble et comme je suis
un je le garde bien de faire des
commentaires sur le café con par rapport
à l'action de ce policier ça veut dire
que si j'avais été dans la même
situation est-ce que j'aurais fait
pareil ce que j'aurais fait différemment
est-ce que j'aurais fait mieux je ne
peux pas le dire parce que vous avez un
dixième de seconde pour réagir je sais
que c'est compliqué à comprendre parce
qu'il a été
je vais vous mettre une balle je vais
mettre une balle dans la tête il a
démarré après avoir été menacé
à l'oeuvre malheureusement elle va pas
il y a pas de Robin Ré si je ferai
réagir Françoise bourg juste après
robareda
est une ancienne préfète donc je pense
que l'ordre public est
quand même elle est sensible et qu'elle
s'exprime en connaissance de cause en
connaissance d'information aussi
moi je voudrais simplement dire que
malheureusement monsieur Jobard non il
n'y a pas eu
deanimité autour de l'appel à la
placement quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pardon oppose le calme à la justice
quand il suppose dans son tweet que il
vaut mieux
faire violence soi-même se faire
violence soi-même pour obtenir la
justice plutôt que d'appeler au calme
dans les quartiers dans les villes de
France pardon c'est irresponsable il y a
pas d'apaisement unanime
avec la France insoumise au gouvernement
vous êtes à la haine
l'exécutif de la France donc
systématique
sème dans les quartiers c'est à dire la
haine de notre drapeau
on le voit tous les jours
la France insoumise c'est la haine de la
France on sait même pas pourquoi il y a
la France dans le monde veut être parti
je vous demande pas ailleurs sur les
refus d'obtempérer elle a une de la oui
de la République de la République c'est
la nuit de la France d'accord
tous les citoyens parce que aujourd'hui
citoyens qui aujourd'hui ont peur de se
prendre une balle dans la tête à cause
de leur couleur de peau d'accord
pardon pour les refus d'obtempérer plus
de 50 % de reculer s'il vous plaît il
faut aussi se poser la question de où
est la faille éducative dans notre pays
pour qu'on ne respecte pas l'autorité
des policiers
d'Europe il ne se passe absolument pas
ça vous voyez toujours pas de problème
alors justement on y vient à la
comparaison s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît c'est suffisamment
grave pour qu'on essaie de débattre de
façon apaiser sur ton sur ce plateau
s'il vous plaît
votre votre regard sur ce qui est en
train de se jouer et ensuite on passe à
la loi 2017 le temps c'est l'analogie
par rapport à 2005 elle est très forte
cette technologie elle a été évoquée
tout à l'heure est juste titre il y a un
élément de cette analogie que j'ajoute
au tableau c'est qu'effectivement les
services publics avaient été fortement
attaqué à l'époque les écoles
maternelles services municipaux et ainsi
de suite savait beaucoup cramé
il y a donc quelques éléments de
continuité par de la 18 ans je le
constate je le note je ne m'étends pas
déçu c'est un fait la
deuxième chose que l'on peut dire c'est
que ça a duré trois semaines
et il n'y a pratiquement pas eu de mort
et ça
moi je ne vais pas me lancer dans le
débat eket Nike sur le recours aux armes
à feu et ce qui s'est passé l'autre
l'autre jour de la justice de faire son
travail
ce que je note c'est que le maintien de
l'ordre la française parce qu'il y a un
maintien de l'ordre dans la française
avec ses qualités ses défauts et ainsi
de suite mais pendant les émeutes de
la police et la gendarmerie avait fait
un job formidable et ça
n'interrompue je ne dis pas c'est
justifiez pas justifié je comprends les
causes
par la France insoumise notamment mais
pas seulement c'est une loi de 2017 sur
l'usage des armes à feu par les
policiers en cas de refus d'obtempérer
que dit-elle précisément on voit cela
avec Stéphanie des pierres et on a les
bas juste après
jusqu'en 2017 la loi est la même pour
tout le monde qu'on soit simple citoyen
ou policier il faut prouver sa légitime
défensive on tire à l'automne 2016 a
Viry-Châtillon 4 policiers sont visés
par des cocktails Molotov jetés dans
leur voiture l'un d'eux et grièvement
brûlé le gouvernement socialiste décide
alors d'assouplir les règles d'usage des
armes à feu pour les forces de l'ordre
que dit la loi la loi votée en février
2017 stipule les agents de la police
nationale et les militaires de la
gendarmerie nationale peuvent faire
usage de leurs armes en cas d'absolu
nécessité et de manière strictement
proportionnée la loi liste donc 5 cas de
figures les refus d'obtempérer en font
partie dans cette situation les
policiers ont le droit de tirer à deux
conditions si c'est le seul moyen
d'immobiliser le véhicule dont les
conducteurs refusent de s'arrêter et si
les occupants sont susceptibles de dans
leur fuite des atteintes à leur vie ou
alors intégrité physique ou à celle
d'autrui en clair si la vie des
policiers ou d'autres personnes est en
danger s'il s'agit uniquement d'éviter
la fuite il est interdit d'ouvrir le
fond pourquoi la loi fait-elle débat la
loi est sujette à interprétation
qu'est-ce qu'un cas d'absolu nécessité
comment définir si l'usage du feu se
fait de manière strictement
proportionnée selon la gauche et
certains experts la loi de 2017 donne
trop de latitude aux forces de l'ordre
combien de morts après des refus
d'obtempérer depuis 2017 le nombre de
morts après un refus d'obtempérer étant
constante augmentation en 2022 13
personnes sont mortes tuées par la
police après avoir refusé d'obéir à un
contrôle routier c'est un record les
syndicats policiers l'expliquent par la
hausse des refus d'obtempérer il y en a
eu plus de 27000 en 2021 1 toutes les 20
minutes
alors on va partir de ce chiffre 13 tir
mortel pour refus d'obtempérer l'année
dernière c'est un record ça c'est
factuel comment vous l'expliquez est-ce
que c'est cette loi qui favorise voilà
le pire pour moi la loi est venue
ajouter de la confusion dans les
fondements législatifs de l'usage de
l'arme par les par les policiers ce qui
est certain c'est que d'un point de vue
statistique un petit peu agrégé sur la
longue durée
on observe que avant 2017 donc 2012 2016
on a à peu près 120 tirs par an sur des
véhicules en mouvement en 2017 la loi
est adoptée au début de l'année 28
février en 2017 on a quasiment on va
voir tout le temps à une infographie qui
explique ça c'est à dire qu'il y a moins
de en 2017
d'armes à feu mais plus de tir mortel
c'est ça
2018-20121
on est descendu à 220 230 bien plus
qu'avant la loi de 2017
parfois s'étire sont mortelles le plus
souvent ils ne le sont pas parfois ils
le sont et effectivement l'année 2022 ça
peut une énigme de ce point de vue là on
a eu 13 morts à déplorer pourquoi je dis
que la loi est confuse parce qu'il y a
un élément qui n'a pas été mentionné
dans le dans le Bref reportage c'est que
en juin 2016 on a déjà eu une loi qui
modifiait le cadre d'emploi des armes et
qui était une loi dite sur le périple
meurtrier les policiers à ce moment
pouvaient faire
usage de leurs armes Orca légitime
défense sur la légitime défense on a
rien touché il pouvait faire usage de
l'heure de leur arme s'ils avaient des
raisons de croire que la personne qui
prenait la fuite allait commettre un
massacre avec son véhicule type 10 14
juillet 2016 et puis il y a eu cet
épisode
meurtrier à Viry-Châtillon une
mobilisation
extra-scinale en fait c'était les
policiers en colère on savait pas très
bien qui c'était qui déclenchait des
manifestations non autorisées qui
manifestaient la nuit avec leurs
brassard avec leur sirène etc il y a eu
peur du gouvernement il y a eu peur très
de vraisemblablement également des
organisations syndicales et puis il y a
cette déclaration de Monsieur Cazeneuve
qui vient abroger la loi qui disait
quand vous tirez c'est pour empêcher un
acte terroriste c'est pas empêcher un
massacre en gros et qui est venu
introduire cette notion que je trouve
beaucoup plus flou et qui doit vraiment
pas être très simple à renseigner du
tout d'ailleurs m'informateur de la
police nationale de 10
menace à l'intégrité physique des
personnes on passe d'un massacre à
l'intégrité physique des personnes pour
moi ça explique effectivement le
l'augmentation qui est quand même lissé
sur cinq ans à chaque fois un 2012
2016-2017 2021 l'augmentation
substantielle des tirs
est-ce que vous vous adhérez à cette
analyse Mathieu Valley moi je vous dis
de choses
je regarde je regarde l'usage des
formateurs
ou pas je trouve pas ça extrêmement
limpide mais je vous le soumets
partager
les policiers parce que alors ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que deux choses
et après s'il faut que je me tue je me
tue et que
ce que je veux dire c'est que de choses
la première il y a eu effectivement 13
décès en 2022 suite à des refus
d'obtempérer qui en fait ont amené des
policiers à utiliser leurs armes pour
protéger leur vie et celle des autres
sur ces 13 décès il y a des enquêtes qui
sont encore en cours et pardon de dire
mais est-ce que lorsqu'on a un
conducteur ou une conductrice je en
général qui transforment son véhicule en
arme et qui donc devient un criminel
puisque les parquets retiennent des
tentatives d'homicides sur des policiers
voire même parfois des homicides quand
on a Eric Mauroy ce policier au Mans ou
Mélanie Lemay cette gendarme à
Pont-Sainte-Marie qui ont été tués suite
à des refus d'obtempérer et ce qu'on
doit laisser des conductrices des
conducteurs tuer des policiers des gens
pour dire les policiers n'utilisent pas
leur arme où est-ce qu'on veut que les
policiers protègent leur vie celles des
autres ça c'est le premier point pour
vous on touche rien
la loi
vous inquiétez pas j'y arrive le
deuxième point c'est que vous voyez
quand vous laissez les gens arriver sur
cette loi de 2007 je suis d'accord avec
vous elle est mal rédigée elle est
malticlée et elle est mal comprise par
les policiers pourquoi parce que je le
dis tout le temps et je vais pas me
dédire ici aujourd'hui c'est que en un
dixième de seconde les policiers doivent
réagir et sur ce 1/10 de seconde il y a
tellement de cases à cocher beaucoup
plus compliqué que ce qui était présenté
à savoir est-ce que c'est le seul moyen
nécessaire pour empêcher la fuite et qui
est en train de décès est-ce que c'est
la seule arme à disposition des
policiers est-ce qu'il y a une mise en
dangereux on n'a pas le temps donc moi
je suis d'accord avec vous quand c'est
mal rédigé et que c'est fou c'est qu'il
y a un et donc du coup vous appelez à
l'abroger moi je suis pas pour désarmer
la police en revanche si c'est pour si
c'est pour si c'est pour si c'est pour
les gens termine vous inquiétez pas si
c'est pour le supprimer et proposer un
article qui permet aux policiers de
mieux se protéger face à ceux qui
veulent les tuer sur des refus de
tempérer en même temps protéger les
autres je pense qu'on peut lancer une
réflexion qui serait utile à tout le
monde officielle
aux personnes que ça soit ceux qui
refuse de tempérer ou des victimes
innocentes de pouvoir être protégé dans
leur vie rebareta c'est important malgré
un peu d'électricité voilà il se passe
des choses sur ce plateau donc est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à rouvrir cette loi
après tous ces fois vous vous l'avez pas
faite c'était avant avant l'élection de
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017
manifestement elle est mal ficelée
je considère que cette loi elle est
importante alors il faut peut-être la
préciser dans son application mais c'est
un vrai débat politique solennelle c'est
où on place le risque de décès
effectivement dans une situation donnée
une situation dangereuse est-ce qu'on
considère que le risque de décès doit
être le risque de celui qui fait
respecter la loi ou de celui qui le fera
c'est un vrai débat politique sur lequel
probablement on sera fabriqué
doivent pouvoir se protéger vous avez
rappelé le drame de Viry-Châtillon je
pense à un autre phénomène un autre fait
dans mat circonscription à
Savigny-sur-Orge en octobre 2020 ou un
policier la nuit s'est fait foncer
dessus par un refus d'obtempérer et le
policier a eu sa carrière fichu et ça
pour ainsi dire sa vie fichue voilà ces
situations elles arrivent aussi et le
graphique que vous avez montré il prend
pas en compte non plus l'augmentation
des refus d'obtempérer donc c'est un
vrai débat que nous devons avoir mais
encore une fois le risque n'a pas
disparu dans la société le risque
terroriste la violence routière dont
tout le monde
explosé sur la route et donc c'est
risque là existent et moi je préfère des
policiers qui nous protègent et qui
peuvent se protéger le mot de la fin
vous avez quand même entendu il y a
moyen de d'ouvrir ce débat et de
réécrire en tout cas se poser les
questions pour je l'entends revoir cette
loi pour terminer mais il faut vraiment
pas jouer avec le feu sans mauvais jeu
de mots c'est à dire que si les gens
veulent un rapport de force dans la rue
c'est qu'ils ont bien peur qu'une fois
les troubles passés l'émotion passé ne
se passe absolument rien j'ai déjà parlé
de l'affaire de la clé d'étranglement
qui devait être interdite qui ne l'a pas
été finalement ça fait 20 ans qu'on a à
faire à ce type de problématique qui ne
sont pas constantes qui ne sont pas le
fait de tous les policiers mais qui
existent et qui traumatise et qui gâche
la vie de trop nombreux jeunes dans nos
quartiers merci d'être sorti de la
polarisation à la toute fin de ce débat
merci beaucoup on s'arrête là il ne fait
que commencer donc on va essayer de
suivre les suites législatives qu'il
aura merci à vous vous restez avec moi
François dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis ce soir
le regard de Richard Werly sur la
décision du Conseil d'État sur le
collectif des hit jabus dans le football
Vincent hugios interroge sur l'avenir de
Wagner en Afrique après la rébellion
étouffée de cette mélisse en Russie et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir de
quoi nous parlez-vous
Myriam c'est tatouage on est tous
contaminés ce sont les écologistes qui
le disent je vous raconte tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord
Françoise bourg on va plonger dans votre
livre les leçons d'une guerre au moment
où cette guerre devient une forme de
basculement du monde et de l'Europe on
en parle ensemble juste après
l'invitation de Maïté vraiment regardez
si on vous invite François Hess bourg
c'est pour nous éclairer sur l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie et sur les
derniers rebondissements militaires et
politiques les leçons de cette guerre
sans équivalent en Europe depuis 1945
sont au nombre de 10 à vous entendre
dans votre ouvrage très documenté de 200
pages où vous disséquez les causes et
les conséquences du conflit dans votre
livre à plusieurs reprises vous
regrettez l'attitude timoré de la France
dans cette guerre nous avons
écrivez-vous étaient petits joueurs sur
le plan militaire adepte d'un en même
temps équivoque par rapport à
l'envahisseur une guerre en Ukraine
dites-vous qu'il faut gagner car elle
est celle de l'Europe tout entière et
qu'il en va de notre intérêt vous
appelez donc les Occidentaux à prendre
leur responsabilité
faut que l'Europe est davantage
d'autonomie stratégique il faut pas
qu'elle demeure éternellement dépendante
des États-Unis qui vont être de plus en
plus impliqués dans les affaires de
l'Asie de l'Asie Pacifique Françoise
vous êtes un grand spécialiste des
questions géopolitiques conseiller
spécial à la Fondation pour la recherche
stratégique vous avez déjà à votre actif
de nombreux ouvrages aujourd'hui aux 491
jour de guerre faites de rebondissements
et de surprises on a bien envie de vous
entendre sur la tentative de putsch de
Prigogine et ses conséquences Poutine
semble avoir sauvé la face mais y a-t-il
vraiment repris la main
réponse réponse ça commençait comme un
putsch et ça finit dans la journée en
autre boudin et mais forcément Poutine
ce qui s'est passé
on est dans un système politique en
Russie qui est un système qui est
l'expression est souvent utilisée mais
elle est juste c'est un système mafieux
à Poutine et le capot dit tout illicapy
c'est le chef et c'est l'arbitre des
lieutenants du chef et
pris gojin lui a manqué de respect pour
dire le moins et non seulement il y a
manqué de respect mais il a mis dans une
situation
extraordinairement humiliante humiliante
pourquoi parce que Poutine a dû faire
appel à quelqu'un qui jusqu'à présent
était sa chose Lukachenko le dictateur
Biélorussie et n'arrête pas de dire à la
télévision combien Poutine lui doit tout
maintenant il doit la vie quasiment et
humiliant aussi parce que les
mutins ont fait l'équivalent d'un Nice
Paris en 7 heures il faut quand même le
faire ils se sentent donc mutinerie est
pas coup d'État avorté pour vous
rébellion plutôt que
c'était des militaires en principe
soumis à une forme de discipline même si
c'était des mercenaires va-t-il se
venger peut-il parce que on l'a vu sur
cette première apparition après après ce
putsch avorté on va voir les images
c'est le chef du Kremlin vous le voyez
c'était mercredi soir dans dans le
Caucase russe il s'affiche très rarement
comme ça et c'est offert un bain de
foule il a fait des des selfies la
distribuer on le voit des poignées de
main il veut expliquer au fond ce qui
s'est passé pour lui c'est une
incroyable démonstration de soutien des
Russes évidemment on imagine que rien
n'est très spontané dans toute dans
toutes ces images mais il peut faire de
cette faiblesse une force encore
aujourd'hui non c'est fini d'abord il
est obligé de se venger il est obligé de
noyer l'humiliation mais l'humiliation
elle reste là elle peut pas être effacée
même si prigogym disparaît je ne sais
pas comment il disparaîtra si c'est par
une fenêtre si c'est dans un accident de
voiture comme c'est arrivé un de ces
généraux hier
parce que on a l'impression que les
purges ont commencé depuis ce putsch
étouffer le général Sergueï
a été selon les médias russes arrêtés
qui est-il d'un mot et que dit cette
arrestation comment l'interpréter si
elle est vraie
sur noms qui est plutôt flatteur c'est
le général Armageddon comme la bataille
d'Armageddon l'autre il est un peu moins
c'est le boucher d'Alep
vous souvenez de la ville de Syrie ou
beaucoup beaucoup de civils ont été tués
sans aucune discrimination par cet homme
au demeurant efficace et moi je ne sais
pas où est sur au Vikings
de prix gaugine
on est dans une guerre à multiples
facettes il y a la guerre qui fait bang
il y a la guerre qui fait tweet mais
vous avez aussi la guerre qui fait
dans le jeu des services alors vous avez
le New York Times qui a un grand article
hier qui explique que sur au Vikings
était le relais de prix gaugine
c'est peut-être même vrai mais il est
peut-être aussi dans l'intérêt des
services américains de déstabiliser le
système russe en faisant croire plus que
peut-être de raison à Poutine que sur
Viking il était là
donc
il faut faire attention on va pas on va
peut-être le retrouver dans un cul de
basse fosse demain je ne suis pas en
train de dire que les informations sur
son instagram
sur le front ukrainien l'armée russe
peut-elle se passer de ses 26
000 soldats de Wagner c'est une vraie
bonne question et la réponse courte
c'est dans l'état actuel des choses
probablement pas c'était quand même ce
sont toujours d'ailleurs
d'excellents soldats ce sont des
salopards sont des mercenaires c'est des
c'est des comme on disait du temps des
mercenaires en Afrique dans la
décolonisation mais ce sont de bons
soldats et les seuls succès que les
Russes ont remportés et privés de
là-dessus elle avait raison au cours des
six derniers mois ça a été effectivement
les hommes de Wagner donc les Ukrainiens
ont une incitation supplémentaire a
poussé leur offensive
pour que l'Europe est davantage plus
vite et plus fort exactement c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui était en train de se
passer on voit les annonces du côté
européen du côté américain
en la matière peut-être peut-être
touche du bois beaucoup de bois et
peut-être que cela amènera les Russes à
aller éventuellement vers la table des
négociations plus vite et qu'il n'aurait
voulu le faire sachant que pour la
Russie il y avait en tout état de cause
un intérêt à attendre les élections
présidentielles américaines avant de se
mettre à table le cas où le Trump
reviendrait aux affaires et ainsi de
peut-être que les horloges vont
s'avancer un peu plus vite d'ailleurs
l'une des leçons au pluriel que vous
tirez dans votre livre c'est que sans
doute les Occidentaux mais surtout les
Européens France Allemagne ont trop
tardé ou tergiverser la page des
atermoiements dans les différents
paliers pour l'aide elle est tournée
pensée elle est peut-être tournée mais
je veux savoir appeler vraiment
l'attention des téléspectateurs sur le
fait que les atermoiements bon c'est une
formule un peu abstraite mais ça veut
dire que il y a six mois sept mois huit
mois de retard pendant lesquels des
civils sont tués des bâtiments sont
détruits des infrastructures sont
bousillées et ainsi de suite alors
qu'avec un peu plus de célérité avec les
mêmes armes je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut développer de façon
prodigieuse la capacité de dest en train
de dire que ce que l'on fait aujourd'hui
on aurait pu le faire il y a six mois et
ce que l'on a annoncé que l'on ferait
dans six mois on aurait dû pouvoir le
faire maintenant dernière question à ce
stade du conflit qui a gagné qui a perdu
entre entre la Russie et l'Ukraine il
est trop tôt pour le dire
mondial est-ce que vous parlez de la
Chine
le grand vainqueur et celui que l'on
attendait pas c'est l'Inde la Chine bien
sûr la
elle a tout simplement parce que tout le
monde va être bien avec l'Inde dans
cette période les sauf les chinois mais
les Russes et les Occidentaux nous
faisons la cour à l'Inde et a juste
titre d'ailleurs et l'Inde c'est quelque
part un pays qui d'une part profite des
circonstances pour son commerce et ainsi
de suite et qui renforce rapport avec
nos pays y compris la France on va
recevoir le Premier ministre indien à
Paris le 14 le 14 juillet pour le défilé
avec l'armée indienne qui sera là c'est
pas par hasard et ben c'est pas les
Chinois qui défilent sur les
Champs-Élysées merci c'est passionnant
on aurait pu continuer longtemps les
leçons d'une guerre c'est passionnant
sur l'ordre mondial qui se qui se
construit et qui est bouleversé sur la
dissuasion aussi l'Ukraine la Russie
l'Asie les États-Unis et nous et c'est à
dire aux éditions odile-jacob vous
restez avec moi Françoise bourg c'est
l'heure des partis pris de nos
affranchis il vous faire réagir vous
allez le voir où on les accueille tout
de suite Vincent Huger le grand
supporteur Vincent et jeu que je suis
sûr vous connaissez bien françoisebbou
ainsi que Richard Berly pardonnez-moi du
quotidien suisse biblique installez-vous
préparez-vous ou commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nationale nous a
raconté ce soir par Marco pommier
bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam ce soir je
vous raconte l'histoire d'un scandale
sanitaire les pie face vous connaissez
non et bien c'est une famille de
produits chimiques qu'on appelle aussi
polluants éternel hier en conférence de
presse à l'écologie stonique Nicolas
Thierry a présenté les résultats d'une
analyse réalisée avec les cheveux de 14
députés du groupe dont lui 40 g de
cheveux au total au service d'une
expérience scientifique objective
évaluée le taux de contamination assez
piface et les cheveux ont parlé
la réalité c'est que nous sommes tous
contaminés qui voudraient de tel
tatouages sur le corps
voilà une mise en scène pour marquer les
esprits des bras tatoués de pictogrammes
c'est 14 députés testés sont donc tous
contaminés par au moins impoliant
éternel alors au total sur les 12
pifastes recherchées 8 ont été détectés
chez ces parlementaires c'est polluants
éternels Myriam ils sont utilisés dans
le cosmétique dans les cosmétiques
l'automobile les poils anti adhésives
les emballages alimentaires mais aussi
les vêtements surtout ces substances
sont rejetées légalement dans
l'environnement par les industries sur
le podium des 14 députés écologistes les
plus contaminés il y a
marie-charlotte-garin écoutez
sur les 12 types de polluants éternels
qu'on a fait tester moi j'en ai 8
présents dans mon corps et dont certains
a des taux bien plus élevés que ceux de
mes collègues je suis une jeune élu j'ai
un mode de vie plutôt sain etc je suis
pas à risque et pourtant j'ai des taux
hyper élevés donc l'intuition qu'on
aurait aujourd'hui c'est que ça vient de
mon environnement et mon environnement
c'est quoi moi je suis député de Lyon à
Lyon on a la vallée de la chimie qui
polluent évidemment et qui a beaucoup
pollué par le passé et l'intuition qu'on
aurait ce serait que ce serait
potentiellement via l'eau potable qu'on
pourrait être contaminé à ces polluences
éternelles alors j'imagine qu'il y a pas
mal de conséquences sur la santé oui un
des conséquences très lourdes d'après
plusieurs études le tableau est assez
sombre cancer altération de la fertilité
trouble thyroïdien augmentation du
cholestérol et de l'hypertension et même
diminution de l'efficacité des vaccins
et puis les pifas sont très résistants
quasi indestructibles le corps ne les
élimine pas résultat et bien on a
retrouvé dans les cheveux des députés
des pie face qui sont interdits en
France depuis plusieurs années le député
Nicolas th pointent la responsabilité
des industriels qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour que ça change concrètement est-ce
que c'est au consommateur de changer
leur méthode de consommation non surtout
pas ça serait terrible de faire reposer
ça sur le consommateur donc en fait la
réponse elle est politique et j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi en ce sens
très simple 1er janvier 2025 en interdit
les polluants éternels c'est biface des
canal des canines alternative 2027 le
temps que les industriels se retournent
pour les produits du quotidien là on
interdit tout le reste en 2027 et
surtout immédiatement maintenant on
contrôle partout sur le territoire
national la présence de ces piphases de
ces polluants éternel dans l'eau potable
le gouvernement l'attitude qu'ils ont
c'est de dire si on ne teste pas il y a
pas de problème donc on a pas besoin
d'agir et ça c'est criminel
alors hasard ou pas à la veille de la
conférence de presse des écologistes le
ministère de l'écologie justement a
publié un arrêté pour imposer à 56
industriels et bien d'identifier et
d'analyser leur rejet en pie face alors
comme on est surnom tous contaminés sur
splato va regarder Myriam je vous ai
ramené les tatouages des écologistes
comme ça si vous voulez vous en coller
sur le bras et ben je vous les donne dès
la fin de l'émission c'est tout ce qu'il
faut un petit tatouage
qui les tatouages représentaient quelque
chose d'extrêmement lourd et
on a changé
de la Fédération française de football
qui prohib les signes religieux n'a pas
de raison d'être modifiée ou contourné
la 3F comme on la surnomme à selon le
Conseil d'État le droit d'éditer ses
règles nécessaires au bon déroulement
des matchs ils ont aussi jugé que
celle-ci sont adaptées proportionnées
vous savez les distinction entre les
joueurs qui auraient bénéficié d'une
certaine liberté et les employés de la
Fédération administratifs ou les Arbites
par exemple qui auraient dû se conformer
à l'article 1 et bien la réponse a été
non le fait taper dans le ballon ne vous
donne pas toutes les libertés ça va vous
plaire à tout le monde j'imagine cette
décision bah oui parce qu'il faut bien
avouer que le Conseil d'État va quand
même à quand même interpréter la loi sur
la laïcité qui je le répète probable
port du voile dans les enceintes publics
et notamment les enceintes fermées il y
a aussi des réalités de tous les jours
qu'on peut voir à Paris c'est-à-dire que
les enfants sont souvent accompagnés en
sortie scolaire par des mamans voilées
et donc comment vous faites le hijab
dans le sport en réalité avec cette
décision se trouve stigmatisée alors que
l'activité sportive a précisément pour
caractéristiques de rassembler toutes
les classes sociales et tous les groupes
ethniques ou religieux vous voyez qu'il
y a au moins matière à discussion alors
on a bien compris c'est contre l'effet
contagion que le Conseil d'État a voulu
se prémunir la FFF est une digue le
football c'est le sport le plus
populaire et accepter que cette ligue se
figure sous ce fissure sous l'effet de
lobbyte musulman aurait eu bien plus de
conséquences que l'autorisation de
quelques burkinis dans des piscines mais
ne risque-t-on pas ainsi d'accroître le
fossé et de pousser dans les bras de
fondamentaliste des jeunes femmes qui
sont avant tout désireuses d'affirmer
leur identité c'est il jabeux elles ont
perdu ce match juridique mais il est
probable que ces jeunes musulmanes qui
sont souvent embrigadés tenteront demain
des prolongations le carton rouge du
Conseil d'État risque de ne pas suffire
pour les expulser des terrains parti
pris signée Richard Werly je vais pas
vous demander ce que vous en pensez
parce que j'aimerais laisser du temps à
Vincent et là je suis sûr que vous avez
envie de réagir Vincent quel avenir des
Wagner en Afrique depuis ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend en Russie et bien bien
loin de minsko de Moscou l'avenir
d'evkni Prigogine et de son orchestre
vagin se joue aussi en Afrique terrain
de jeu au combien lucratif et cible
prioritaire de la stratégie d'influence
du Kremlin sur le continent noir comme
ailleurs l'équipe et rebelle de Wagner
puis ça piteuse volte-face laisseront
des traces bien sûr le ministre russe
des Affaires étrangères Serguey lavrof à
claironné en plein tumulte et avec un
empressement suspect que cet épisode
n'entraverait en rien le labeur des
coopérants venus du froid en République
centrafricaine ou au mali business has
yujuro de même les despote subsahariens
russophiles ceux qui ont scellé avec le
camarade prigogène impact Faustin peigne
la sérénité à d'autres car un vent de
panique a soufflé à Bangui ou Bamako
comment se fier à un capot mafieux s'y
prend à mordre la main du parrain
Poutine qu'il a façonné puis nourriez
quid du mythe viriliste du tsar Vladimir
implacable et redouté par les siens
alors
pas précisément occupe l'Afrique dans le
système trigogine Concorde la structure
qui coiffe les activités de Wagner
s'apparente à un conglomérat
tentaculaire une pieuvre pour filer la
métaphore causanostra et le père via une
myriade de d'entités écran sur trois
fronts 1 le militarrosécuritaire
mercenaria instruction encadrement de
l'armée locale protection rapprochée du
chef de l'État 2 les affaires sous la
forme de razzia méthodique sur les
ressources naturelles hors diamant bois
précieux exfiltré en partie via le
Cameroun vers Dubaï et Moscou pi 3
l'espace informationnel médias réseaux
sociaux fermatrol mais aussi
manipulation aux électorales avec le
concours du mort rémunéré de rémunérer
de propagandistes gravitant dans la
diaspora tel le franco béninois Kémi
Séba ou la Suisse d'origine camerounaise
Nathalie Yamba alors expliquez-nous un
petit point pardon avant Myriam
où on est Wagner en Afrique selon les
services de renseignements occidentaux
première sévit dans une douzaine de pays
d'Afrique citons le Soudan dès 2016 donc
la RCA depuis 2018 le Mali à l'été 2021
encore la Libye et tant pis si à ce
stade les sodas de prigogi et de
demi-trioutine sont spadassins néonazi
ont davantage brillé dans la prédation
et l'exaction que dans leur compas
frontal contre le fléau djihadiste
soudains
mardi hier l'ONG de sentry qui explore
les réseaux de captation des richesses
en zone de conflit armée a publié un
rapport glaçant et locament intitulé les
architectes de la terreur et consacré au
méfaits des chiens de guerre russes en
Centrafrique une cinquantaine de
témoignages recueillis auprès de
victimes civiles mais aussi de soldats
du crus massacres torture pillage viol
de femmes enceintes et de mineurs à
peine 10 ans voir de militaires
rechignantes à infliger les sévices
qu'on leur enseigne alors soudard
barbares à vous de choisir alors
qu'est-ce qui va se passer avec cette
mutinerie avortée est-ce que pour moi le
système en Afrique perdurer le scénario
le plus probable à mon sens c'est une
tentative de mise sous tutelle par le
Kremlin de la mouvance Wagner quitte à
promouvoir d'autres sociétés militaires
privées à la loyauté pour le coup
insoupçonnable la Russie ne peut pas se
passer de cette tête de ponts africaines
pour le pactole qu'elle lui procure bien
sûr mais aussi pour l'audience et l'Eco
garantie dans l'hémisphère sud à ses
diatries
occidentales le tout au prix d'un
paradoxe ébouriffant ou sans lisse
d'ailleurs une fraction de
l'intelligentia du continent c'est au
nom du souverainisme que l'on abdique
tout ou partie de sa souveraineté et
c'est en vertu du combat contre
l'impérialisme que l'on cautionne de
Mario Paul à Bangui une entreprise de
nature coloniale Françoise bourg une
réaction
Wagner et Concorde en Afrique
à la différence de ce qui se passe pour
Wagner en Russie et fabrique de l'argent
ce sont des entreprises rentables
autrement dit
si les a tortionnaire moi je l'appelle
tortionnaire surtout que ce boucle trop
poli
il y a les tortionnaires de Wagner
veulent continuer à sévir en RCA ou au
Burkina Faso ou au Madagascar ou au
Mozambique parce que la liste est longue
il pourrait le faire un peu comme il
avait fallu des années au Congo Aix
belge à l'époque pour éliminer les
mercenaires font des affreux par Poutine
des wagnères forcément donc ça pourrait
continuer sauf que
Poutine a quand même deux leviers l'un
et politique bien sûr parce que la
Russie est toujours importante pour
défendre les intérêts des dictateurs des
pays concernés aux Nations Unies et il y
a ça et mais il y a aussi la capacité et
qu'à qui a eu jusqu'à présent l'armée
russe d'approvisionner au plan de
logistique de la logistique militaire
les moyens de Wagner notamment Libye et
et au Mali et mais
il y en a pour un moment voilà c'est pas
fait merci merci beaucoup poursuivre
d'ailleurs cette conversation lisez les
leçons d'une guerre chez Odile Jacob de
Françoise bourg merci à vous les
affranchis à très vite Marco pommier
très belle soirée sur LCP à demain
[Musique]